I'm Jonathan Brower and I'm a Scoutmaster with Troop 19 in Fort Wayne, Indiana. This edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me. Thank you for all your insight
and your experience. You help me be a better Scoutmaster. And now for you. Scoutmaster
Tom Brer is a Scatter with Scouts Canada, with the third Orleans Scout Group in Ottawa, Ontario,
And he said that he suggested that his Scouts make Brad at camp, But unfortunately they pan
the idea and they got downright crusty about it and said: don't not suggest that again.
Yeah, I mean, the least you can do is keep calm. Maybe just loaf around a little bit, Tom, I don't
know. Oh, my Thanks, Tom, I think I think if you've got a better one, send it in. Hey,
welcome to podcast number 224.. Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look at the mailbag.
We heard from Jeff this week, who said thanks for putting all this knowledge in one place. I often
use the blog, whether I'm looking for something I'm interested in or I'm using it as a reading
assignment for new Scoutmasters. I'm helping to train. Well, thanks, Jeff. I'm glad you're
finding what we put out useful. We also heard from Steve Kearns, who's an advancement chair
with the Portola district. He said: I just wanted to tell you, after months of procrastination,
I became a backer today. Well, thank you so much, Steve. I'm going to let everybody know how to do
that in just a moment. I wanted to share with you how I found you and why I became a backer.
About 18 months ago, I became the advancement chair for our district. after having been
our troop advancement coordinator and guiding several Scouts through the Eagle process
and being the district merit badge counselor coordinator. I was fortunate to get to attend
Fillmont training center last summer and take the advancement course, which is, by the way,
where I learned of your website and podcast. That training experience opened my eyes to the lot
of false tribal knowledge that substitutes for actual knowledge in Scouting. I learned to
rely on the Guide to Advancement 2013,, which is an excellent explanation of the Scouting program
and the advancement program. The training really energized me to elevate our district's advancement
program away from some of the methods that treated advancement as the goal rather than only as one
of the methods we use to achieve our mission in Scouting. I started listening to your podcast
right after that and I haven't missed one yet. Each time I listen, it allows me to relive my
Fillmont experience a bit and renew my newfound understanding of the advancement program as
it fits in the overall program. I get a lot out of your messages. I'd ask if you could include
more information for those of us who support Scouting outside the troop and the pack level,
as there's a lot of things district and council and Order the Arrow folks
could learn from some of your advice. Thanks for all you do Well. thank you so much, Steve,
for being in touch, And I do hear from a number of district and council people
in Order the Arrow folks too, And if there's anything that I could include that would
be helpful to you, let me know. I certainly would appreciate hearing from you. And again,
once again, Steve, thanks for your thoughts and your kind words and for becoming a backer.
Now, last week I did one of my favorite things: I was able to get on the phone and talk with
Youssef Hasi, And Youssef is over in Alexandria, Egypt, where he's a Scouter.
I, incidentally, talked to him in France, where he's going to school right now,
but they're getting ready to wind up and he's going to be heading back to Alexandria for a
summer of scouting, And I love to talk to people all over the world about scouting,
because when I do, I invariably find out that we all have this incredible world of experiences
and the scouting spirit in common, And it doesn't seem to matter where you are in the world. I've
talked to people in in the different European countries and in the Middle East and in Africa.
My intention was to record our conversation but I kind of messed it up-
Sorry, Youssef, And I was going to feature some of it here on the podcast, But let me tell you,
wherever you go in the world, if you find a fellow Scouter or Scouter,
you know that you have this common experience and you know that you are connected. Our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell. he saw scouting as a way to foster understanding and world peace
And I've got to say, a hundred years later, it is doing exactly that. I'll be off to
Kandersteg Scout Center in Switzerland this summer with a group of our Scouts And I'm really looking
forward to that because I know I'm going to get to meet Scouts and Scouters from all over the world
And it's just a fantastic experience. It's something that I highly recommend to you.
Get your Scouts into one of those great international situations where you're
going to meet other Scouts from all over the world. You learn so much and you share
so much. It's such a great experience And I want to thank Youssef for taking the time to talk to me
and apologize for not being able to have the recording here, But what a great thing to do
And I recommend it highly to you. Let's see. Last week on the blog we had several different posts.
One was a story about special needs scouting And it got me to thinking about the question:
isn't every Scout in one way or another a special needs scout? I mean, they're all
individuals. They all have their own talents and challenges. They all have their own family
backgrounds and upbringing to deal with. Everybody has those kinds of needs
And if you haven't read that post, go back and read it, because it features a story
about a Scout and his dad who's involved with scouting, And this particular Scout
is identified with Asperger's And it talks a little bit about their experience and how Dad's
handling it and how the Scouts handling it. Scouting is a great place for everyone,
no matter what their perceived limitations may be. It's just a great place to learn about people,
to learn to get along. Chris Simone, who's the Scoutmaster of Plandom Troop 71,
wrote in about that post and he said: thanks. I have Scouts who are identified with this sort
of issue, So advice is always worthwhile. Well, I'm glad that you found that helpful, Chris.
I also posted a new infographic last week, And this one was backpack basics-
just explaining the different things that you want to look at when you're getting ready to choose a
backpack. That infographic is available at scoutmastercgcom, as is our PDF package,
which is a collection of over 40 infographics and other helpful PDF documents that you can get
by going to scoutmastercgcom. Just follow the link at the top of the page
and you'll be able to find out how you can get the downloadable PDF package.
Then we had a couple of excellent posts from Enoch Highsey in Green Bar Life that talk about
strategic impressions, And if you haven't read those posts, make sure you take a look at them.
share them with your Scouts, especially those who are in positions of responsibility.
It brings a new perspective to the Scout motto: be prepared. that I think you'll find
very useful. So make sure to take a look at that and also share it with your Scouts.
Now. earlier we heard from Steve Kearns, who became a new backer this week,
And I want to tell you just very quickly if you are getting something out of the podcast
and the blog posts and all the other resources we create. you can become a backer
And the funds that we get from backers are used to support the creation and publication of
all of these resources, including the blog, including the podcast, And I want to take
a moment just to once more to say to Steve Kearns and Brian Ehrler: thank you so much
for becoming a backer in this past week. We really, really do appreciate. it keeps us up and running.
Well, this week, in Scout Mastership, in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk about
building campfires. It's a metaphor. okay, You'll see. you'll see what I mean.
It's a message that is in answer to a very common set of email questions that I get.
And, speaking of email questions, I have some specific ones I'm going to share with you.
after Scout Mastership, in seven minutes or less, That's going to take up the rest of
the podcast, So let's get started, shall we? Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
You know, this past week I received a couple of email questions
that had a common theme And, I tell you the truth, pretty common email question that I get:
The two Scouters I heard from along this theme the past week. we're asking:
what do we do to get our Scouts to care about the program? I mean that was the basis of what
they were thinking, And you know what I mean about this. right, There are times when it seems
that the Scouts we're working with just don't get it right. When Scout Spirit kind of abs,
when we have a camp out or two, that kind of fizzles out and nobody seems to be very
interested in, when things just aren't going right. It's like an old preacher said.
it's kind of you know something's wrong but you're not quite sure what it is. It's kind of like
washing your feet with your socks on. I also get that kind of question a lot of times from folks
who are poised to become Scout Masters in the near future. They survey the troop they're about
to take over and they see any number of problems. They think there's a lot of changes and difficulties,
that there's a lot of changes they're going to need to make and difficulties for them to overcome.
And I'll tell you from experience: this is a really crucial moment because we look at a situation.
it makes us unhappy. we don't find it, we don't think that we're getting anywhere with it
and we have a very strong temptation just to take over and set things right, right
To change everybody's mind and to make things work, And usually we're going to do that at the expense
of having Scouts have the experience of beating themselves and making their own decisions about
things. So I want to encourage you to look at this carefully and look at it just a little
differently than you may be looking at it. What I've learned over years of experience is that our
job is never really about making Scouts or our fellow Scouters do anything. It's never about us
being able to issue edicts and orders and have everybody follow it. I think you probably
understand that, because our fellow volunteers are volunteers. Our Scouts also volunteers
And you know, if I'm volunteering for something, I'm not going to be real interested in hanging
around if there's one person ordering me around and telling me exactly what to do.
I think our job is creating an environment of opportunity that offers Scouts the growth
and discovery and friendship and adventure of Scouting. This is all great stuff, right,
And as they do the do it all, as they go on the camping trips and work in their patrols and
take on responsibilities and work towards advancements, they start to grow and mature into
the kind of young people we aim to develop. They have no idea that this is happening
And it's probably one of the farthest things from their mind when they join Scouts.
They join Scouts to have fun with their pals. That's what they're in it for.
So exactly how do we get them to care? How do we get them to care about advancement?
How do we get them to care enough to show up at meetings and events and to take on
the challenges of Scouting and make good? Well, here's a thought that came to me.
Imagine we're out camping and the evening starts to grow kind of cold. Well,
we could decide that it's too cold out and kind of give up and head for our tents and
our sleeping bags. or we could build a fire. Now we're going to set to gathering wood and
assembling the tinder and the kindling and we're going to clear a spot for the fire.
We're going to find our fire starters and our matches, We kindle the fire and we add the fuel
and soon we're enjoying the warmth and the fellowship that it provides. But it's not
always that simple right. I mean many, many, many years ago. I can remember very vividly
setting up in a state park and it was cold and rainy and I really wanted to have a campfire.
It had rained for a few days previous and things were really soggy and I tried and I tried. I even
think I threw some liquid stove fuel on the wood to try and get it going. It wasn't a smart
thing to do then and it's not a smart thing to do now, But I did everything I could to get
that dang fire going and it just would not light. I felt like I spent an hour or so trying,
and I've watched my scouts do this too. If you've been around for any length of time,
you've watched it. right, They try this or that. They get a pile of leaves, They get a pile of
grass, They fret and they fuss. There's a lot of smoke and a lot of bother and arguing
and they get frustrated. Maybe they end up with a fire, Maybe they don't.
You know, whoever said where there's smoke, there's fire was clearly never a scout master,
right? I know one thing: If you go about building a fire systematically, if you gather the tender,
the kindling, the fuel carefully, you're going to have a fire. So I think the real question to
ask is to sit back and look at your scout group and ask yourself the question: where are you
in the process of building a fire? Are you still shivering in the cold? You still got people out
gathering firewood. Are you to the point where you're able to kindle the flame, or are you
or do you have a campfire going and you're singing songs and enjoying the fellowship
of the campfire? You know you may start out with no place to build the fire. There's no
fire ring, So you've got to start at square one and clear the ground and gather rocks and
make a fire ring. Maybe somebody keeps coming along and dumping water on the flame every time
you get it going and you may need to get them out of the way. Maybe you're in one of those campsites
that's pretty picked over and there's not much firewood to be had, which means you got to go
farther afield for fuel. Maybe it rained all last week and the fuel is wet and your fire
is sputtering and it's really, really difficult to get things going. Maybe nobody thought to
bring matches or fire starters, So maybe you've got to make a spark or put together a fire by
friction kit to get things going. The point is, no matter what's happening, you have faith in a few
simple laws of physics. You get the fuel, the air and a source of inspiration or ignition together
and you will have a fire eventually. It may take a lot of work and it may take a long time,
but you will overcome the conditions, you will create the proper conditions and you will actually
have a campfire, No matter what's happening today or happened yesterday in your scout troop.
have faith in the program. The program works. Get the program going and you're going to
achieve the aims of scouting. It's just the same as the simple laws of physics that control
the idea of a fire right. When we know that, when we create the proper conditions, when we get the
right fuel and kindling and tinder together, we have a source of inspiration or ignition,
we're going to have a fire. We know, if we get the scouting program going, we're going to achieve
the aims of scouting. It's worked for more than a century now, in every corner of the world.
It's worked. It's going to happen. It's as sure as the laws of physics. In my experience
I've had very few campfires spring to life instantaneously with one match And, as I said,
I've watched my scouts try one idea and clear the fire pit and try again. I've seen plenty
of piles of wet leaves sputter out and inadequate attempts at gathering the fuel and 100 other
missteps to getting things going. But you only learn by trying right. The only way you learn to
build this fire is by giving it a shot. I can't give you three steps to instant success, to make
the scouting program go or tell you exactly what needs to happen next where you are.
All I know is that there are a few immutable things that work, that have always worked and
that will work without question, just like building a fire. Apply the program faithfully, Keep after
it and you're going to see results. It takes longer than anyone imagines at first. It takes
faith and persistence. How many times have you seen a campfire grow slowly from a sputtering little
flame that nearly disappeared? I know I've seen that happen many times. Think big. Don't get too
concerned when one scout shows up for something. Concentrate on that scout. Don't get too discouraged
when things fall flat, Prop them up and start over again. Most of all, this requires being patient.
It requires being patient with yourself, because you're going to make more mistakes than you can
count. But if you persist in doing good work, it will work. The program has to work.
So but you tell me, listen, I've tried all this before. I've tried these things.
Well, you've got something wrong. It can't be the program. right, You've got something wrong.
And don't get too upset with that. Be patient with yourself. You're going to make a lot of
mistakes, just like I said, Your tinder's wet, Your kindling's the wrong kind,
You don't have the right kind of match going. whatever it is, You're just going to have
to keep at it until you figure out what the right combination of things is. If you've been around
for a while and you've instructed people on how to build fires and you've watched the process
unfold before, you know that it's a fairly simple, straightforward process, But it can be
tremendously frustrating if there's one little thing out of place. It can be tremendously
frustrating, right, If something is wet, or you don't have the right kind of matches, or you
don't have the right kind of fuel. If it's like I said, if it's been raining or something like that,
it can be a really difficult process, But you know that it will work And that's the kind of
faith and confidence that I want you to have in the scouting program. It's much easier to get on
a podcast and to state you know the very simple rules of fire building than it is to
actually build one in the field, And I know that. But we're going to be here to answer
your questions and to see if we can help you get that fire going. But the best news of all
is that it has to work and it will work. You just have to keep at it.
That is, folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Due to the sensitive nature of this email, I've been asked to keep the sender anonymous.
But they wrote in and said I was asked to coordinate a small group of scouts
to do an opening flag ceremony for an upcoming political party breakfast.
It doesn't really matter which party it is. Suffice to say, I feel uncomfortable asking
my scout families to participate in any partisan political event. I have a coordinated groups that
do a flag openings for the Rotary Club, But that wasn't a specific political party
And I really didn't think about a set a second, about participating in that.
Where exactly should scouting draw the line on requests like this? I definitely want scouts to
be prepared to make moral and ethical choices. I want them to be good citizens and participate
in all aspects of the rights and duties of citizenship, But I'm a little worried that
getting involved with a partisan event might not be appropriate. This answer is pretty easy,
because I didn't even have to come up with it. There's an applicable policy statement
issued by the Boy Scouts of America And I'm going to read that statement to you,
with the understanding that not everybody listening is involved with the BSA.
I think this policy would be very familiar to scouts anywhere. Let me read it to you.
Uniformed unit members and leaders may participate in flag ceremonies at political events
and may lead the Pledge of Allegiance. However, they should retire after the ceremony and
not remain on the speaker's platform or in a conspicuous location where viewers
could construe their presence as an endorsement or symbol of support for a particular political party.
In addition, photos of candidates with scouts in uniform or any BSA marks or logos are not allowed
in political campaign materials of any kind. Volunteers and professionals must be alert to
situations that would imply the BSA favors one candidate over another. Strict observance
of our long-standing policy against active participation of uniformed scouts and leaders
in political events is mandatory. So I think it's a pretty simple statement, right? I would include
that policy statement in a letter to the folks who are running this political breakfast and either
be there yourself or have a detailed discussion with the scouter who will attend and lead
the scouts through this- And yes, I think this is one situation where an adult should be telling
scouts precisely what to do. I'd require the folks running the breakfast to allow time to rehearse
the movements of the scouts and what will be said precisely. They should provide a representative
or coordinator who will acknowledge the policy statement that I've just read and that you'll
include in your communication to them and be the go-to person at the event. As you said,
this is a good thing for scouts to do, so long as everyone involved understands very carefully
exactly what they're doing. They're there to acknowledge their citizenship and to celebrate it
with the people that are gathered there, not to endorse any specific political ideology.
As a side note, I'd suggest you instruct the scouts and adults not to literally physically
touch a button or a poster or any piece of political paraphernalia while they're in uniform.
It should go without saying that we don't ever wear political buttons or anything like that on the
uniform, but let's say it anyway. This would assure that nobody will walk away with a picture of a
scout holding a sign or wearing a button or appearing to do so. If a candidate or a speaker
requests photos with scouts, I would respectfully decline citing that to your understanding,
this is not permitted by national policy. Of course, participating in this event gives you
and other scouts a really great opportunity to discuss politics and citizenship and how our roles
as scouts differ from our role as private citizens. Why aren't scouts involved in politics?
What's the difference between your role as a scouter and your role as a private citizen?
Now, I'd say all this acknowledging that, yes, this kind of thing can be a little bit of a
minefield, but it's a great opportunity for character development for our scouts.
So we want to be sure we have a solid understanding of the dividing lines and that all the adults
involved are on the same page before you start discussing it with scouts. I think the key term
in the policy statement I read is construe their presence as an endorsement or symbol of support,
and that's the point to discuss with everybody involved. If you can't all agree on this,
I would pass up on the opportunity and move on In an abundance of caution. I want to make sure
to restate that there is a specific policy. I've read it out here on the podcast. That's where it
all begins and ends. I've added a little bit of advice of my own. but whenever it comes to matters
of policy or procedure, you should always back up whatever you hear here, whatever you hear
from somebody else, whatever you assume is right, by going to the resources that are provided by
your scouting organization, not just making an assumption of what you think is right or listening
to what people tell you is right. You read the resources yourself and if you still have questions,
get in touch with your local scouting officials and ask them for their help. Here's an email exchange
I have with Tom. Tom first wrote and said: I have a young patrol that only wants to meet on
Sundays and once a month at troop meetings. They're even asking to make their own calendar
and I'm really not sure how to deal with this. And then I asked Tom: who's driving the idea on this?
Is it the scouts in the patrol or could it be possible that some adult or parent is involved
in doing this, And what does the senior patrol leader and the rest of the patrol
leaders council have to say about it? Tom wrote me back and said: I'm not sure. I just received
an email message about this and all the scouts involved with the patrol are pretty young, They're
below first class. And the email said we've decided and we're going to start having our meetings
on a schedule that allows the scouts to be involved in football and soccer season.
Not all the scouts in the patrol will be able to make regular troop meetings.
We'll be having a calendar planning meeting at such and such a scouts house at such and such an
address. And we also came up with two goals to achieve over the next six months And therefore
everyone in the patrol to rank up once and to do three eagle required merit badges.
And Tom said I did give them a simple and positive reply. but I really can't get my mind wrapped
around what's going on. And my reply to Tom was: it's not likely that a scout is driving this
and wrote that email. Now it could be, but I would say in my experience, after reading the email
and considering its content, I don't think a 12 year old scout is likely to be the source of
this. could be, but this sounds more like a mom or a dad kind of leading the patrol, much like a
den leader would lead a dent And it wouldn't be too hard to figure out exactly who that parent is,
because it's probably the parent of the home that they're meeting it. So I don't think this
sounds like such a bad plan, but the parent involved needs to get some perspective on what
happens in a scout patrol and troop. If the scout patrol is made up totally of younger
scouts, they need the benefit of the instruction and leadership of the older scouts in the troop.
So exclusively having meetings outside of the troop meeting they're not going to get that.
I would contact this parent and I would sign them on as adult leader and get them trained.
And it's a good opportunity to recruit an assistant scout master. And then you need to
start working with them on how to make this happen in a way that benefits not only this
patrol but the entire troop. Tom wrote back and he said I spoke to my senior patrol leader
and he's concerned. He asked: why are they with the troop if they just want to do their
own thing? And that's really a good question, isn't it? I asked him to call the patrol leader
and ask a bunch of questions. I'm trying to let the scouts lead on this, But it appears
I have some untrained parents and I'm still trying to find my feet. so far as the scout
master job is concerned, Your advice is truly appreciated and hopefully we'll get it worked
out Well, Tom, I don't have a problem with the patrol setting their own course. I think it's
actually a very positive thing. The problem here is is that it's not likely the patrol
but a parent who is a couple of degrees off course and doing the decision making.
Hopefully it'll come to a quick and simple resolution for you. Let me know how it works
out, Won't you? And here's an email, and I think I'll keep this one. I keep this one
anonymous as well. Our pack has quite a few families where there's a non-parent
involved, A significant other of a scout's parent. We're planning a pack camp out
Based on youth protection policies. my inclination is to say that the non-parent
significant other is welcome to participate and may even spend the night,
but probably shouldn't share the tent with the scout and the parent. What do you
think? Well, that's a really good question, but I
haven't been able to find any specific policy advice on it.
My best reasoning is only that, My best reasoning. I want you to make sure
to contact your district executive with this question for an authoritative
answer On a pack camp out. I suppose it be
expected that parents in their cub will share a tent.
Perhaps a better way to handle this would be having the cubs share tents without
parents, And the cubs would probably like that arrangement better.
but if that isn't going to work well, here's what I would suggest.
If I were in your shoes, I would send a memo or a communication
as a part of the information that you're going to share about the event.
that says something like: as a reminder: here are specific youth protection
policies that we will observe during our camp out,
And I would include the policies on two: deep leadership,
one-on-one contact between adults and scouts and the separate accommodations
for scouts and adults, And I think the statement that
specifically bears on that is: when camping, no youth is permitted to sleep
in the tent of an adult other than his or her own parent or
guardian. Note that it says parent or guardian,
And we really can't control who a parent assigns guardianship to.
That seems to be a call that's totally up to the parents.
I understand your concern, but I think the approach that you suggest
could lead to problems that are probably best avoided. Do you want all the couples
accompanying scouts to show you a merit certificate.
I mean, you see what I mean. It kind of gets complicated
If you start defining non-parents, significant others.
you're kind of second guessing the parent and that could be a point of
contention with some people. It seems to me that parents get to
define guardianship of their children And our policies reflect this,
And I'd like to know what advice or direction you get from your district
executive or, if you're listening and you've
encountered this before, how you resolve the issue.
Once again, only my advice and my thinking
in a situation like this. that definitely needs to be backed up
by specific knowledge from a scouting official.
Jason wrote in and said: the troop I'm working with
shuts down in the summer for almost three months,
It seems. every September when they start meeting again,
we've lost several scouts and it takes some time to get things rolling.
In your experience, shouldn't troops meet year-round?
On top of that, the previous leadership has insisted on 12-month leadership
terms for scouts. They say: we're a large unit, these
boys need more time to lead. I say: we're a large unit and these
boys need shorter terms to allow more scouts to get a
chance to lead. I may be the unit leader sometime soon.
Who's right about these things? It kind of drives me a little crazy.
Well, Jason, there are a few right or wrong answers when it comes to the
questions you ask. There are always ways that work better than others and
different styles of getting the job done. It's like making coffee.
I really don't care if it's percolated or dripped or pressed or expressed, so
long as it results in a cup of coffee. right,
For the answers that you want to the who's right and who's wrong,
I'm not going to be a whole lot of help, but the answers, in setting the way
forward, are going to come from the scouts. I would suggest that you ask them,
Go to the Petrolators Council and say to you guys: think that 12 months is too
long a term or just about right? Do you think we should change that?
Let them have a voice in that. Let them figure it out. Do you think it would
be a good idea if we did some things over the summer? and what would you
like to do? Introduce the idea to them, see if
they think it's a good idea, Discuss all the issues involved. They'll
come up with a plan. Now, the first few times you ask these sorts of questions,
you'll get a look like a dog looking at a new pan right?
Nobody's asked the scouts about this stuff before.
They're likely to be confused and even a little suspicious. you know
Why isn't they asking us about this? We've always done stuff this way.
Why would we want to change it? But keep at it and ask lots of questions
like this. Keep the questions short and listen
carefully to the replies. In most places, scouts have been
conditioned by adults to sit around and wait to be told what to do.
They have no idea that they could change things around
or stop doing some things or start doing other things.
I note that you aspire to be the new unit leader,
but you are not actually the new unit leader yet, So I'm going to counsel you
to hold on with these questions until you are, Otherwise
you could be looked on as interfering or being a troublemaker.
After all, if you were the unit leader, you wouldn't want somebody
doing that sort of thing without your say so. right,
It may be frustrating, but until you're the one in charge,
specialize in observing and listening, You know. take some actual notes,
Think things through. If you're recruited to lead the unit, then you just have
some ideas to get started with. And finally, one more anonymous email.
I had a discussion with our advancement chair the other day,
One of our scouts began two merit badges with one counselor
and then switched to another counselor and completed them.
Now this isn't all that unusual, but the counselor that he switched to
happens to be his father, And the other counselor
had told our advancement chairman that it surprised him that the scout
completed the badge in such a short period of time
when there was really quite a bit of work remaining for him to do.
I replied that since the scout's father is a registered merit badge counselor,
we would award the badges as we had received a completed blue card.
The advancement chairman suspected that the parents
may have been doing a lot of work on behalf of the scout,
spoke to them about it and that didn't go all that well.
I also heard this concern about the parents of this particular scout
being a little over involved from two other merit badge counselors
and assistant scout masters. I did look at the guide to advancement
and it's clear that a parent can sign off for a son
and that a scout may choose any registered counselor.
The guide also says when a scout is earning a large number of
merit badges from just one counselor that the unit leader can put a limit on that,
but the term large is undefined. I don't want to interfere in a family.
I defer to the parents as they're raising their sons
but the best interests of this young man's experience in scouting
and the health of the troop in question as well, I'd love to know what you
have to think. Well, as you've found and as I have found,
looking into how other families conduct themselves or relate to their children
is like looking into my great grandfather's old pocket watch.
I mean, I can see things spinning and clicking. I could even point out the
balance wheel, maybe a couple of parts of the movement,
and I'm fascinated with taking things apart. I remember as a boy I
disassembled an old typewriter or two and then they never saw the light of
day again. right, They remained a big pile of parts.
You know, I look at that old pocket watch and I even have a couple of watchmakers
tools and I'm sorely tempted. but thankfully I'm old enough and
experienced enough now to know if I took that watch apart I'd never get it
working again. So I've learned not to meddle,
just to apply the rules, just as you're doing with this family.
Don't meddle, just apply the rules. We have them right there in the Guide to
Advancement 2013.. Your advancement chair was rebuffed
when he spoke to this family because he was really kind of trying to meddle.
I say that in all charity for how laudable
his or her intentions were, but all that's needed really is applying the rules,
even the ones that you don't particularly like,
and it sounds like you have a handle on that Now. the Guide to Advancement
does have some open-ended statements that invite local interpretation, like:
how large is a large number of merit badges?
I would suggest, instead of trying to objectify that answer for
everyone in the troop by answering it with one set number,
talk to the parties involved. they're best suited to do this for themselves.
I'd share the applicable verbiage from the Guide to Advancement 2013
with the parent in question and say: it's obvious that your son's going to
become an Eagle Scout, so, in the interest of not causing any
difficulties for him regarding this, I want you to set a limit
on the number of badges where you're going to be the counselor.
Now, I often tell people things like this on the blog and the podcast,
forgetting it took me some time to have the confidence to do this myself.
If it helps, I can tell you that, through long repetition and experience,
it works. I think you're approaching this in a really good way,
with the right spirit. You can't control the relationship between a parent and a
scout or how families operate. We have a set of rules that will help
you preserve the experience of the scout, and the best way to apply them
is to make the scouts and the parents aware of them
and work with them on interpreting them and putting them into practice.
Hey, listen, if you have an email question for me, you can get in touch,
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, you've been listening to the 224th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch. Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
Now while you're there. you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can also get the Scoutmaster CG app on Google Play or in the iTunes app store.
That way, you have all of the resources that we create right there on your mobile device.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
as they are through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Join the 5600 folks who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus of 1,050 tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pulitzer Student's Pictures. profit publicly with 1,500 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us on Scoutmaster CG on YouTube.
Join the 400 odd folks who form the exclusive Scoutmaster circle on Google Plus.
But listen, we can't all face Facebook, can we?
Twitter makes some of us bitter. Some of us have no interest in Pinterest.
Some of us don't put the? U in YouTube.
Some of us are a minus when it comes to Google Plus.
If that's you, don't worry, Bunky, You can zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
Yes, email me, Clark Green, your questions and comments and wild ideas
at clark at scoutmastercgcom. It's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of
America, nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America, or any other
scouting organization for that matter. No, it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders. and you know, have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time, everyone.